Did you fall from heaven because...I have
no idea what I'm talking about or whether
you like me at all.
Hey guys and gals, I’m Trace for DNews!
Let’s talk about sex, baby.
Specifically, let’s talk about how we talk
about it without talking about it.
When someone is interested in someone else,
usually they don’t walk right up and announce
it.
Instead people rely on the ancient art of
flirtation.
A smile, a joke, a double entendre if you
know what I mean.
We do this because flirtation tends to have
a better success rate than outright declarations
of attraction, according to a University of
New Mexico evolutionary psychologist.
But declarative statements, while robotic
and off putting, at least have the advantage
of being unambiguous.
Flirting?
Not so much.
First of all, people can have a lot of different
reasons for flirting.
According to research out of Northern Illinois
University, there are six reasons people flirt:
casual fun, testing the waters, increasing
intimacy, boosting self-esteem, trying to
gain something from the other person, and
of course, expressing sexual interest.
So the miscues happen when men and women misinterpret
signals.
Women either read too much into subtle clues
or miss them entirely about evenly.
Men, on the other hand, see false positives
way more often and tend to see what they want
to see.
In a forthcoming study in Personality and
Individual Differences, researchers from Union
College and Harvard asked nearly 500 men to
imagine a woman in a nightclub who notices
she’s being stared at and smiles back.
That wouldn’t be my reaction if 500 men
were staring at me but anyway, the men were
then asked to gauge her level of interest.
First, the men were rated on whether they
craved intimacy, or whether they distrusted
it.
Those who ranked higher in distrust tended
to think women were less interested in them
and didn’t see the smile as flirtation.
But the men who craved intimacy tended to
project it on the woman.
In other words, they imagined a completely
hypothetical woman smiling at them and thought,
“Oh yeah, she totally digs me.”
Even when non-imaginary women are involved,
men aren’t so great at reading their body
language.
One study from the University of Indiana asked
280 male and female undergraduates to look
at pictures of women and determine if they
were being friendly, sexually interested,
sad, or rejecting.
The female participants hit the mark more
often, while the males tended to read too
much into friendly body language.
It’s tempting to think this is because men
are always looking for sex, but actually men
often misread cues in the opposite direction
- they mistook sexual cues for simple friendliness.
Another small study conducted at the LWL University
in Germany examined 22 men in fMRI machines
while they looked at pictures of men’s and
women’s eyes and tried to guess what emotion
they were feeling.
These men took longer and were less accurate
when guessing womens’ emotions, and their
amygdalae, which help interpret emotions and
empathy, were less active than when they looked
in men’s eyes.
Of course, not all men are terrible at taking
a hint.
Some are quite skilled at it, while some women
struggle.
But overall, according to some social science,
men are more likely to wrongly assume a woman
is interested in them, than the other way
around.
So how do you tell what she’s thinking without
blowing it?
Luckily for you, Tara has a video explaining
the correct way to flirt.
Check it out here.
Let’s do a
little science too, guys and girls.
How often would you say you misread clues
and picked up on something that wasn’t there?
Or how often were you completely oblivious
to someone else’s advances?
Let us know in the comments, or on facebook
or Twitter @DNews, it should make for fun
reading.
Subscribe for more and I’ll see you next
time on DNews.